Українські спортсмени беруть участь вже у сьомих Літніх Олімпійських іграх. За цей час були і злети, і падіння на Олімпіадах.
Чого досягли українці за роки незалежності?
Олімпійські ігри в американській Атланті стали рекордним дебютом для українських спортсменів.
Україна вперше виступала як незалежна держава і здобула 23 медалі, у тому числі 9 золотих.
Це були найуспішніші Ігри в історії України, досягнення яких у наступні роки побити поки не вдалося.
У загальному заліку українська збірна була в топ-десятці.
Саме тоді стала справжньою зіркою юна Лілія Подкопаєва, здобувши три медалі - дві золотих та одну срібну.
А Володимир Кличко здійснив свою мрію і став олімпійським чемпіоном серед важковаговиків.
Після приголомшливого успіху в Атланті через чотири роки у Сіднеї Україна суттєво "просіла".
Олімпійська збірна, щоправда, здобула також 23 медалі, але вже не 9 золотих, а лише 3.
В підсумку - 21 місце у загальному заліку.
"Золотою рибкою" тих змагань стала плавчиня Яна Клочкова, яка "виловила" в австралійському басейні три медалі - дві золоті та одну срібну,
а на дистанції 400 метрів ще й встановила світовий рекорд.
Третє золото українській збірній приніс Микола Мільчев у стендовій стрільбі. Жодного промаху і теж світовий рекорд.
Крім того, українці здобули 12 срібних медалей. Якби хоча б ще одна золота, то увійшли б у двадцятку найкращих олімпійських збірних світу.
Ці Олімпійські ігри були майже такими ж успішними, як і дебютні в Атланті. 22 медалі, серед яких 8 золотих.
Знову відзначилася Яна Клочкова, здобувши дві нагороди найвищої проби.
Також по два золота українці взяли у гімнастиці - Валерій Гончаров та Юрій Нікітін, а також у боротьбі - Ірина Мерлені та Ельбрус Тедеєв.
У загальному заліку Україна посіла 13-те місце. Щоб повторити рекорд в Атланті, не вистачило однієї золотої нагороди.
Після Олімпійських ігр в Пекіні Україну позбавили кількох завойованих там медалей через допінг.
Але навіть попри це, в підсумку Україна здобула, як і в Афінах, 22 медалі, хоча на одну золоту менше - не 8, а 7.
Попри це, у загальному заліку українська олімпійська збірна опинилась на одну сходинку вище, ніж чотири роки тому - на 12 місці.
Яна Клочкова цього разу не "виловила" жодної медалі. Але в підсумку вона залишається найбільш успішною олімпійською чемпіонкою України,
здобувши 4 золоті та одну срібну медалі. За виняткові спортивні досягнення Клочкову нагородили званням Героя України.
На Іграх в Пекіні особливо вразили українські фехтувальниці.
Програючи у фіналі китаянкам аж вісім уколів, вони в підсумку таки вирвали перемогу.
У боксі ж блискавично переміг усіх суперників Василь Ломаченко.
Пристойно виступили українці й на Олімпійських іграх у Лондоні, хоча і з дещо меншими здобутками. 19 медалей, з яких 5 золотих.
Шостої золотої у важкій атлетиці Україну позбавили через допінг.
Зрештою у загальному заліку збірна опинилась на 14 місці.
Боксер Василь Ломаченко, як і в Пекіні, впевнено виграв олімпійське золото.
Його товариш по команді Олександр Усик теж здобув найвищу нагороду.
Вразив публіку й український веслувальник-каноїст Юрій Чебан. У Пекіні він був третім, а тепер довеслував до золота.
На Олімпіаді в Ріо Україна здобула лише дві золоті медалі. Юрій Чебан доплив до свого другого після Лондона золота.
А гімнаст Олег Верняєв виборов перше місце на паралельних брусах і йому трохи не вистачило до золота у гімнастичному багатоборстві.
У підсумку в загальному заліку Україна посіла 31 місце з одинадцятьма медалями.
Це був найбільш невдалий виступ на Олімпійських іграх, якщо не брати до уваги нинішню Олімпіаду в Токіо.